beginning of the war in Ukraine Millions
since the beginning have escaped their
homes and found safety across the world
many have come here to Las Vegas looking
to find a new life away from everything
they know but tonight the community came
together to help those starting over
connect with others in a similar
situation Sasha Loftus joins us now live
with more
[Music]
Denise and Brian a lot of the people we
spoke with tonight came from Ukraine
here to Las Vegas just a few days ago
they escaped a war to come to a place
where they don't know anyone and don't
even speak the language tonight's event
was meant to make that process a little
easier
terrible that's the only answer
as War rages on in Ukraine dozens born
and raised there have found a new home
in Las Vegas two of my close relatives
they're soldiers right now in the war
Louisa novitska shares the agony of
watching those she loves deal with
unimaginable conditions a world away
it's horrible because you want to be
involved in there you want to help you
want to save she and many others
including some who just escaped the
destruction gathered in Centennial hills
Friday night ahead of the holidays I
said what can we do to help and she said
we need friendship we need to connect
with other families Kimberly McGee
organized the friendsgiving event for
Ukrainian refugees who need help
adjusting after so much fear and
unimaginable trauma it can be very
lonely in a new country you don't speak
the language you don't know where to go
to do just the basic things Luisa says
it's comforting to connect with others
who understand the love for the country
they've all left we realize that oh my
my God my goodness there are so many
ukrainians in here we even didn't know
that as thousands get ready to start a
brand new life here locally new
possibilities New Life
such things
another issue many mentioned tonight was
the continued blackouts in Ukraine which
can get more dangerous as the country
starts to deal with a severe winter so
the group we spoke with today is
planning a lot of holiday event
fundraisers to help those they know
still struggling in the war-torn country
reporting live tonight soccer Loftus 8
News Now